Hey you-- go take a hike!
No, seriously…go do it.
Thank me later…
Hey nature enthusiasts, Jules here for DNews.
You may have heard about the healing effects
of the great outdoors—specifically on our
mental health.
Being in nature can reduce stress, depression,
and anxiety, boost your mood, and impact other
mental functions.
But it turns out nature doesn’t just have
an effect on our minds -- it can also improve
our bodies.
Simple exposure to greenness, or natural vegetation,
has been shown to produce biological benefits
for our physical health and can even help
you live longer.
A study published in 2014 in the journal Environmental
Research examined green space proximity as
it related to stroke survivors.
After observing around 1600 survivors living
in the Boston area between 1999 and 2008,
researchers concluded that green space was
indeed associated with higher survival rates
after having a stroke.
Scientists suggested this could be due to
factors associated with nature – lower levels
of stress, better access to social networks,
and opportunities for physical activity.
Walking in nature can also have a positive
effect on people with Type II Diabetes.
A Japanese study at Hokkaido University School
of Medicine found that diabetic patients who
took walks in the forest over a period of
6 years had consistently lower blood glucose
levels.
According to the study, outdoor environments
prompt changes in hormonal secretion and nervous
functions that can benefit insulin sensitivity
and blood glucose levels.
But another study published in 2012 found
that a mix of green and urban environments
may actually be better for you than just surrounding
yourself with nature.
The study from the journal BMC Public Health
observed 11,000 adults in Perth, Australia
and looked at places that had variable greenness,
which they define as areas with an “aesthetically
pleasing natural environment” plus “access
to urban destinations.”
They examined the link between variable greenness
and coronary heart disease and stroke, and
it turns out areas with high variable greenness
were associated with lower odds of hospitalization,
even lower than just predominantly green neighborhoods!
They say, [quote] “in terms of cardiovascular
health … both green and non-green areas
are necessary within walking distance, rather
than vegetation alone.”
They attribute this to the fact that in neighborhoods
with highly variable greenness, people will
walk around their environments more, thereby
increasing physical activity and overall health.
A variety of other studies show greenness
is associated with decreased obesity, increased
cardiovascular health and lower levels of
childhood asthma.
Researchers suggest that this is not just
due to physical activity but also lowered
exposure to air pollution, extreme heat, and
noise in vegetated areas.
Nature can also help the body heal, too.
A 1984 study published by the American Association
for the Advancement of Science found that
patients recovering from abdominal surgery
whose rooms overlooked trees, had an easier
time recovering, including needing fewer and
less extreme medications, and had shorter
hospital stays than those patients whose rooms
faced a brick wall.
The research suggested that simply viewing
natural environments has restorative effects
on both emotional states and physiological
activity – prompting faster recovery.
A 2008 study published in the journal HortTechnology
observed 90 patients recovering from appendectomy
surgery who were assigned randomly to rooms
either with or without indoor plants.
They showed that those with plants had lower
blood pressure, less pain, anxiety and fatigue,
and greater satisfaction about their rooms.
Of course, further research is needed to learn
exactly what it is about the natural world
and its mechanisms that affect our physical
health, but with this body of evidence suggesting
there is value in nature, why not try it?
Add a little green to your daily routine -- you
may be on your way to a longer, healthier
life.
So now that you know all about the physical
benefits of nature, what about what it’s
doing to your brain?
We cover that in this video right here.
What’s your favorite outdoor space to go
to?
Tell us in the comments, subscribe, and keep
coming back for more DNews.